two welcome everybody it is that time of
year with the special edition 2022
Silent Library
yeah obviously
as you can tell we haven't started yet
here's the decibel counter
set we're gonna just do a little bit of
a segment here at the top just talk and
say what's up and then everyone's gonna
come sit and we're going to do our
Asylum Library last year was a huge hit
fan favorite so we're gonna make it a
tradition so we are here
and do it again
yes yes today's episode is sponsored by
stamps.com thank you so much to stamps
we love that
uh members episode is up by the way had
a great time streaming
um and it was a lot of fun actually 5
000 people were watching the members
live I thought that was pretty good
they're not great it's pretty good you
didn't uh docs us this time too so yeah
I'm getting better another W I'm getting
better
[Applause]
um you know I want to apologize to ninja
yesterday is being posted on Wednesday
so on Monday
I went in a little bit hard on him I
said he was Zig hiling and uh
360 no scoping prisoners that was too
far
it's a little much
he would well
you're right it's not funny and well you
know what
he would even though he would be doing
sick trick shots on prisoners
it's just not funny and he's right he
could probably do 720 no scopes on
prisons but that's neither here nor
there because it's not funny to joke
about yeah I don't think he'd be
shooting prisoners he for sure would be
doing 1080
no scope no lookie
um in the uh
yes and the uh oh God what was it the
[ __ ] who's that Keanu Reeves movie where
they got the skin in fortnite oh John
Wick yeah John Wickes yeah maybe that's
not even the funniest example maybe it's
like
and Thanos skin they have Thanos in
their eyes yeah yeah Thanos skin you're
gonna Thanos snap
Jesus and that's not funny though
it's not funny but I'll tell you what is
funny
ninjas
um
Ninja's a pedophile no I'm just kidding
but he is
[Laughter]
he did comment on uh the I'm just joking
I'm just making a joke because he he
speaks on the Balenciaga thing and uh
let's hear what he has to say one check
out the check out the drip by the way a
little Fortnight
um yeah so there you have it what a pro
you heard it here folks ninja I I'll
I'll let it go on the anti-semitic nose
comment but on the Balenciaga drip not
good dude this dude is a he's Pro
grooming he's Pro uh and I'm just I'm
just laying it on you know we're we're
talking a lot about Ninja based on that
one clip and I'm still a little bit
hesitant because I wish I could see the
chat for that clip because what if
someone said uh your nose is so big are
you Jewish and he's like am I Jewish no
I'm not but my nose is Big because that
changes everything that does that does
change everything he didn't say that
though no but we don't know what prom we
don't know what problems don't you think
someone would have showed us that if
that's what it was a different idea I
don't know maybe yeah I mean Bradley
Martin clip of you uh talking about how
working out is [ __ ] and the
purposely yeah but that one's cut the
[ __ ] up you could tell that come on
somebody would have showed us the
original yeah true
but either way he did call you out for
the whole Twitter thing
no that's fine I just you know what I
mean um but this who can defend this I
mean Ninja needs to answer for this
that's a firm space
actually did a collab with fortnite that
is insane yeah I didn't know about that
dude hey do you want to pay 800 for this
like blank with this is fortnite on it
can we really talk about this though
yeah we need to sound bite that Zach
and and also if Dan if you can add a
button that just pops this on screen
that kind of dissolves it in and out
okay could do that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
man the resale of these fortnite
Balenciaga shirts are insanely seriously
yeah 1500 send me the link I'll pull it
up you've got to be kidding me dude what
a suckers dude what suckers holy [ __ ]
far-fetched Balenciaga fortnite this is
1100 bucks for the hoodie
although I bet the imsrp is probably
somewhere around that so you know what I
mean yeah I can't imagine it was much
cheaper
let me read the back on this
retail row
oh it's just a bunch of what the [ __ ]
does that even mean uh retail I believe
that was an area on the fortnite map oh
okay okay okay okay
[Music]
think it says we love babies
yo it's in the there's a document under
the hoodie that says something about
yeah a court case no not again I'm
fluent in code that's how I know Frank
man this is really disappointing you
know what I mean
he needs to answer for this now is this
clip from like a Euro because I do see
that this collab was from uh 2021 yeah
oh this isn't a new clip
I'm asking I'm just asking questions
here well he needs to burn that shirt I
mean he needs to do a showing where he
burns the shirt and Defiance I'm
assuming it's an old clip oh you making
assumptions yeah
that's all the clothes in fortnite too
fortnite yeah it was a skin as well well
more than skin you can like play it look
forward
so before night Jesus
why did people like this brand by the
way
yeah just imagine just imagine Ninja
doing a
2160 no scope off the guard Tower in the
back of the head no snipey no look no
look
there's no way he would have been in the
SS dude there's no way why because
clearly he would have been fighting on
the Eastern Front
oh you think he you yeah he's more front
line
okay
well if he's a trick shot or he'd be
posted on the guard Tower no have you
ever seen Enemy at the gates dude battle
Stalingrad sniper battles [ __ ] sick
as [ __ ] I think they put him out there
but he you know some some guards they
requested specifically I want to be in
the camps because I I want to you know
inflict the maximum pain on these people
and I can see based on that Jew knows
comment that he might want to do a 10 20
no scopy no lookie uh 1050 Ford flip
he's not about he's not about crushing
noobs he want you know he wants he wants
to play against this who's our nudes now
Dan yeah
in this analogy
AGA oh my God fortnite Balenciaga
I could do this all day don't test me
all right
anyway
so ninja ladies and gentlemen Pro
uh p word alrighty uh so yes we love uh
we love ninja folks we kid ninja we like
to uh give them a hard time but he is a
great fortnite player nobody could take
that away from him I wonder when the um
the Auschwitz DLC is coming from
fortnite
yeah you know it's interesting it's an
interesting opportunity
for uh Ninja yeah specifically
yeah
pretty interesting dancing in the
showers DLC oh that's absurd come on
shame on you
took it too far
yeah uh Riley Reed by the way was on no
jumper podcast
and she was talking about a time that
David dubrick was making her super
uncomfortable trying to push her to have
sex with dom
uh it's so [ __ ] up it's actually so
interesting this just came out and in
the context of everything we know about
him
it really speaks volumes let's take a
look
dobrik's YouTube video he's has a camera
on me and he goes do you think uh my
friend Dom is hot and I was like yeah
he's cute he's like would you kiss him
and I was like yeah I'd kiss him he's
like would you kiss him right now and I
was like oh I'm under a little pressure
I'm in a room of like 12 people playing
up this Riley Reid Persona filming this
David dobrik video and he's like would
you come I was like yeah again playing
up Riley Reed Persona and then he's like
would you come right now and I was like
uh and then they're like okay like let's
go into the room and they like they
basically like pushed me into a room
with him he starts like talking to me
about wanting to do stuff and everything
and I was like oh
can I ask him I was like when's the last
time you were tested and they were also
talking about how he just had some like
the night before or something right and
he was like I haven't been tested in
like three weeks or something I was like
well I'm definitely enough you I felt so
lucky that he didn't get tested because
then I got to end the video on such a
beautiful positive note because I was
like guess what he could have me if he
was tested but he's not so make sure you
get your
shout out my pie by the way uh
get tested folks yeah it's kind of
interesting that even Riley Reid who's
like you know empowered woman
independently wealthy uh felt so much
pressure from David putting his camera
in her face that she was she was it
sounds like was going to be coerced into
sleeping with dom if he had a clean bill
of health yeah
knowing what we know now that's
horrifying and considering how already
open she is sexually by her own choice
the fact that he was able to make her
uncomfortable in a situation like that
speaks
why does it also like why does he he
treating like because she does sex work
he's treating her like uh almost
subhuman in a way how it's like he
doesn't give her any heads up it's just
like come over here and put the camera
in your face okay now you're gonna have
sex with dom right
that's what you do right so you're gonna
go and have sex with my buddy
so nasty dude what a what a [ __ ]
freak that little dude is also can you
imagine that like energy shift from I'm
in front of the camera David's like
laughing and then the door closes and
it's just like being like so like let's
go now yeah and Dom's like yeah you mean
yeah yeah I can't even imagine Dom's
ready to talk shop because obviously
he's a r word yes too
so shout out to Riley Reed who luckily
got out of that situation but yeah
people have been buzzing about this clip
we try to find the original upload on
David's Channel Zach was unable to find
it we found this re-upload of the clip
though on YouTube sounds like he
scrubbed yeah
also also the fact that this hasn't
become like a bigger story I feel like
just because she's a porn star it's not
even taking taking very serious
afterwards well here's the here's the
second or the most upvoted comment on
this clip with uh I'm sure this is a
tater tot does she not know how to say
no this is like um keemstar logic like
how do you assault someone in the mouth
remember that yeah just close your mouth
just close your mouth according to Keem
uh dear Kali man
you know I went to Dom's channel to see
if he posted anything in response and
his latest video from 23 hours ago is
h3h3 exposed for cucking
it's two hours two minutes and 28
seconds should we watch it I mean I hate
to even give him attention because he's
so irrelevant and he's obviously trying
to bait me but maybe it's fun
entertaining anyway I haven't vetted I
could watch right now or we could do it
live
let's do it live [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
doing live yeah this is really you make
a great Point love I mean if this was
anyone else people would care but yeah
they making the same assumption David
did which is that basically
it's funny she she has like almost no
agency she's just like a s like a
inanimate sex object yeah it's weird
does she not know how to say no
boy you are [ __ ] dumb as hell did you
watch the video like if any woman is
gonna be comfortable saying no it's
gonna be her so really it should tell
you more about the coercion that men
like David can can exert over women and
not vice versa yeah and like how
disorienting that experience probably
was going yeah I did room to room
also David is like in this extreme power
position you know I mean what does he do
then does he just sit in the living room
and listen yeah that's his that's what
he's into
you know what
that's weird oh yeah
he talked about one of his biggest
fantasies would be watching his girl um
having sex with someone else I did not I
remember that I just
I did a practice like that it's weird
you know he had to ear to the door or
possibly a camera in there I'm not even
gonna front that dude had a camera in
the fire alarm yeah you know he did
he's [ __ ] up like that people still
lining up for doe bricks though by the
way speaking of lining up for dobricks
when we getting some of that I know some
stuff about doe bricks I watched a
review they're not doing full pizzas yet
you gotta pull that a little closer
they're not doing full pizzas yet just
slices just slices and a maximum of
three uh three per person and the box
that they like are they selling [ __ ]
Adderall or slices David like went on
this whole thing about how beautiful
their circular box was with The Branding
and it is beautiful it's stunning but
that's not the box that they were giving
people I just want to taste it
uh Sam went yesterday
um because we were using it for
something in Silent Library today and I
told her to get some extra for us to
review it and yeah it's the three slice
maximum she waited in line forever and
she could only buy three wait we have a
slice here no we had to we had to use it
for for the segment today yeah but
there's three slices in the building
right now not as the way you would
imagine this oh my God you couldn't save
me like one virgin bite is there one
virgin bite
Sam there's is there one virgin bite of
dobre sorry
oh damn no
how was this how are you getting it Sam
uh
well I had to wait in line forever
and
sorry
I had to wait are you trying to strangle
her or around 45 minutes or so and they
were only letting like three or four
people in at a time
um and it's kind of set up like Sparrow
I think that's how you pronounce it if
you've ever been to like yeah
you can only get three slices at a time
and
um it's just like whatever they have
under the like warmer the heat lamp what
kind of dude three what are you talking
about three slices that barely been one
personality they're on the pizza what
happens if you go with a friend
uh I mean then your friend can get three
for more than three and they're like no
um well I asked for a whole pizza and
they said they can only do three slices
oh my God and then they also had ice
cream
um oh there was this every like five
minutes
the lights would go off and they would
play All I Want For Christmas the Mariah
Carey song and there would be like
strobes in a disco ball for like 10
seconds is that that's probably the coin
gimmick thing where you put a coin and
like the lights go on and off oh really
I didn't know yeah with the pie but I
was wondering why it was happening so
much but I didn't get a coin every five
minutes I knew that thing would be each
other it was awesome it was extremely
annoying so yeah but um
I did so I had to cut the pizza up for
in a certain way for what I had to do
with it today and I did take a little
bite
I must say okay go ahead and
um it was the ratio from crust to
topping was like four to one not good
the crust is like this thick and the
there's the thinnest layer of toppings
on top well it is dough brick after all
it's extremely good
eating a loaf of bread I'll throw no
bread
was there a back room in the pizza place
where uh people could hook up and David
can pick recorded watch yeah I mean
there was a kitchen that had a window
you could see into the kitchen so voyeur
you put a coin in and then you can go
drink coffee you can go David will watch
watch the peep show yeah was there a
lemon on ice cream
uh I don't know
um they just gave me two scoops I don't
know if there's a limit what was the
flavor dough ratios were crazy but how
was the flavor
it was fine it was really dry oh I got a
spicy vodka and
two meat lovers and the meat lovers was
fine the spicy vodka though it was just
it was really dry unforgivable pathetic
hmm do they have honey on it
no I didn't I didn't see the one that
had honey on it I wonder if that was the
pepperoni but they were out of it when I
was ordering so I don't know interesting
absolutely
pathetic the ice cream was the worst
part it was
horrible I had to like do a palette
cleanser to get the taste of it wait
tell me everything why it just tasted
horrible was it soft serve or was it
Scoops no it was scoops and I don't even
know what the flavor was supposed to be
it's called Blue Moon and it was like
baby blue oh blue balls as David watches
as his friends hook up in the in the
back room of the pizza joint flavor
flavor that is how I would describe it
okay perfect
bottom line is you cannot be trusted he
cannot be trusted with the pizza how is
the parking situation the ratios are off
the parking was there was no excuse me
I'm trying to do there's no we're the
facilities like uh
well what excuse me what was the excuse
me please did they have a public
bathroom
excuse me sir I know y'all don't care
about that
excuse me he disrespected the Italian
people my kids are seven percent Italian
Dan this is actually an important issue
to me and I don't appreciate y'all
trying to make a pair yeah seven percent
she's 15 Dan okay don't [ __ ] step to
me my kids are Italian have Italian
Heritage this is important that's what I
do you know you've been calling people
fascists a lot lately you know who is
Italian
Benito Mussolini okay so what I'm just
saying they're fascists whatever bro how
did Aiden Ross pronounce it like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] his name up yeah you
fastest
as I was saying did they have uh titles
on the floor was it concrete you don't
care about if there's tiles or concrete
how is that relevant at all was the
brick Exposed on the building where it's
called Dirty was a dough brick so yeah
you guys are asking ridiculous questions
stop
was there a parking enforcement parked
in my God I actually had to park at
Saddle Ranch and I had to tell them oh I
was like I'm going to pick up a ubereats
order and I just went and I was gone for
45 minutes but I didn't say anything got
him David dombrick is disrespecting the
Italian people
a three to one ratios
It's Italia phobia do you think he pays
Mariah Carey residuals
um for every five minutes you should be
guys that's just irrelevant he has no
pizza she is the queen it doesn't have
Visa experience
he comes to me he sells three slices
what is this what is this the Great
Depression is this post World War One
famine we have plenty
my friend if I come to your pizza place
let me get a pie cannot be trusted you
cannot be trusted
hmm anyone want to ask about like if the
how have they had hot water did you have
hot water was there hot water at the
sink in the bathroom that is important
you know you kid electrical
you washing your hands with cold water
bathroom there I don't I didn't see it I
maybe I mean I'm sure they did but I
just didn't see it this place
let me just put it this way
if you go to Italy and you sit with a
fine cappuccino espresso
[Music]
and you get yourself a whole pie Pizza
this the bread is it's paper thin
that's the way Italians do it to come
and disrespect me
next to the Saddle Ranch another fine
Italian Institution
the Saddle Ranch I don't know yeah
Saddle Ranch is an Italian spaghetti
western they probably got better Pizza
dog [ __ ] dobre yeah this is Italian
phobia though I think Dan canceled David
dobrik for Italian phobia this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] my kids did not my kids
do not survive all they've been through
get seven percent Italian genetics just
to deal with this [ __ ]
cosine do you know what ela's Dad went
through to bring that 15 Italian all the
way to Israel that's just not easy
garbage but I do
it's a lot of tomato sauce
now were the dance lights LED or were
they neon how could they how could she
even know that cam you can know they
were neon okay there you go and uh wait
they were neon lights no well there was
like colored like strobe lights and a
disco ball and right it was a lot it was
like a club in there what was the okay
okay okay stop
I am curious though what was the vibe
like in there what were the people like
what kind of people were in there
um cut the music Zach it was just like
young people think like I don't know
younger than us or just the way he likes
him like I don't know 20s actually kind
of there were some people like I would
say 16 to 24 was like the the vibe in
there so like us
yeah well like you and me and
most of us people I'll take that
actually all right guys listen uh shame
on you David dobrik for all you've done
it to the Italian people and that's just
the beginning so there's that we've got
uh do a brick actually I have some uh
breaking news some gaming news actually
that I think you'll be pretty interested
in
go ahead oh no DLC new DLC announced are
you [ __ ] anymore fortnite you [ __ ]
yo wild ride to Auschwitz what the hell
dude yo we need that you need to add the
ninja skin and a guard Tower please
cam it's not ready
Fortnight Wild Ride the Ultras this is
crazy can we show this
we showed you this is a rehab this is a
replay this is an old meme from the show
what yeah we did this this what was the
contact oh we already we already made
that yeah it was uh we made a bunch of
Goofs on yeah can you add ninja and uh
uh Ninja skin in a guard Tower please
you know I think it was when we were
making fun of the uh Martin Luther King
that's what it was yeah event that they
did
yeah I heard I heard ninja was making
bomb threats to the MLK virtual event
literally in Minecraft like in you know
Fortnight in fortnite ninja was doing
that and I was like man that's [ __ ] up
dude I know it's in a virtual space but
still it's not cool yeah I'm not I hate
all this ninja slander man
I can actually say it in Minecraft
behind that because that's what I'm
talking about in video games yeah in
fortnite maybe in Minecraft this past
day maybe it should be in fortnite now a
bomb threat in fortnite Minecraft's a
kid's game we play fortnite now oh my
God yes
okay [ __ ] do you guys want to talk all
right let's do this EDP this is like
such a downer intro we're like
we're like uh David we actually only
have about four minutes left before the
break time
um
so I don't know if you want to get into
that already because it's probably going
to be long I do four minutes EDP I'll
just blast through it so you guys know
edp45 he was a actually he called into
the show like years ago which was
interesting
um but I haven't talked I don't know I'm
not like besties with him so let's just
back off that
um
excuse me he got caught meeting like a
14 year old girl like last year 13 13.
oh
uh for a for a cupcake
and uh that's what he claimed yeah that
he was grabbing a cupcake and then he
was gonna go home
yeah yeah no one's buying it it was if
you didn't hear about it it was
absolutely insane
he his channel got erased the man's life
was just absolutely turned upside I
think he went to jail for a minute and
it's interesting because he was actually
getting big on YouTube people were
diving with him hard he was like this
absolutely
unhinged sports fan
and I will admit he he he was funny
until I found out you know he's a
trying to assault kids he didn't go to
prison that sucks the humor out you can
go to prison or jail but he lost his job
and his house
oh yeah people
I'm not saying this is this is good but
whenever he found a new job or some [ __ ]
people were like
tracking his every move and calling his
employer
it's kind of wild for the you know I'm
not but that's just that's just what was
happening so anyway he's back on the
internet do we have that uh Tick Tock he
posted I want to show that as an intro
do you know the one I'm talking about
I like
Loosely remember it yeah I don't even
want to say it because it ruins a
surprise wait I don't yeah he posted a
viral tick tock
so
uh is our home right right
yeah
um
a YouTuber blah blah blah so the new
situation is essentially he's back he's
been trying to claw his way back and
it's kind of incredible the amount of
people that actually don't care
and are kind of like EDP dub so here's
edp's big comeback video he posted this
was from She's what's the date here
eleven six so this is last month about a
month ago
and he got the cupcake guys
pretty wild right yeah that's like a
wild [ __ ] post but I guess you
got nothing to lose at this point [ __ ]
he's like yeah I did that he's like yeah
I try to hook up with with a 12 was it
12 or 13. yeah I try to hook up with a
13 year old
this man is
I mean the the only next move for him is
try to become like a bishop or some [ __ ]
you know what I mean
because they just move him like a city
over and he'd be good yeah
yeah but so the comments are actually
kind of weirdly supportive imagine 80P
walking into your cupcake shop and he
orders a cupcake what if bro really just
wanted a cupcake he got the cupcake it
took him two years but he got it
he was innocent the whole time uh
um
Jesus Christ loves you okay so it's not
bro kept his word
you know what I mean
um so there's not a lot of hate here
let's go
you know let's go
so he's making his big comeback right
and and actually I think he's actually
getting some fans back again right so
here's a recent video he posted all
right y'all what is this one is from
last month
it is man so he's just back to talking
Sports wait man
yeah you stop [ __ ] kids bro the wait
is the least of your issues I need to
lose weight you got to set a priority
you need like a hierarchy of needs bro
and losing weight is important but
stop [ __ ] kids is more urgent
you know what I mean
uh the comments sugar-free cupcakes
that's a good suggestion
I love you so much like whoa dude and
that's got a lot of likes
yo crazy
bro finna get all the little girls
[Music]
yeah so and this this video has
260 000 views this one has 700 oh that's
the cupcake one yeah that one was kind
of viral
so anyway he's having his big comeback
and guess what he's back he got caught
again
oops and these people don't change and
that's kind of
not to make it's about James Charles but
because I know it's not about him but
it's just to make a point is that these
types of people who have these
pathological
impulses uh they don't change and James
Charles is one of those people
yeah I can tell we really uh you're
really in shambles about it Hello Olivia
so this
yo what play that again hello Olivia
what the f
what the f what the something you want
to tell us Olivia no I don't I don't
know I don't know him singing You songs
and [ __ ] I don't know him yeah so no
jumper posted EDP got exposed again for
trying to get with an underage girl
uh here so what you're seeing here is
their tax exchanges and the girl talking
over it I'll read the text first he said
to her don't let anyone ever tell you
you aren't beautiful not even me
it's a weird kind of like really Noble
of him planning on that you deserve the
best and trust me if I was in Louisiana
I'd be beating down your door okay
kind of a
double-sided comment
uh smothering you with flowers and hugs
oh thank God he's FL he's peeking at her
door to give her flowers uh you just
better prepare yourself because I'm
showing you off to the entire world oops
and so here here she is talking about it
you knew what he looked like right
I was just really trolling him like in
the group chat like when we made that
she sounds like a child
and like he just took it too damn far
like he started like personally like
dming me
and like
say he fell for it again cry me out and
he's gonna like
fly her out
so on here it says don't think she needs
a chaperone to fly
or he could ask keemstar for advice yeah
you know so you want beautiful not even
yeah keem's advice would be waiting uh
let's see uh 12 months
then announce it then announce you're
dating
just lie about her when she uh you know
I'm gonna go there Louisiana it'd be a
beat down your door smothering you with
flowers and hugs you just better prepare
yourself because I was shouting you off
the entire world that's the corniest
[ __ ] ever
you knew you yeah pretty wild so there's
EDP welcome back to the internet uh we
wish you
all the best
he responded on his Instagram oh for
real he tagged the girl uh he's trying
to claim he's innocent because she said
she's 18.
so this is this one I love this kind of
Defense because James Charles is a lot
too I mean James Charles is like at
least
22 or 23. edp's in his 30s uh but the
girls obviously she has her her
account's private now but when we saw it
um
it had her graduating high school year
so she's in high school just listened to
her voice dude yeah
oh man there it is so welcome back
we need a support group with keemstar
ADP and James Charles they can maybe not
and once those guys start comparing
notes
as trouble for the for the communities
out there
amen
all right well that was a really cheery
start to um
the podcast but worry not
because it is Silent Library time oh let
me let me thank our sponsorstamps.com
and then we'll get right into uh Silent
Library
thank you to stamps I love me some
stamps
stamps.com just rules it's the holiday
season I know everyone's gonna be
mailing stuff cards packages going to
the post office right now is going to be
such a tremendous pain in the butt and
there's no reason to with stamps.com you
can get the services of the post office
and the convenience of your home with
fat discounts
foreign check this out up to 86 off USPS
and UPS shipping rates because they have
such bulk orders
it's on freaking real dude you don't
have to think about it dude yeah
um it's not too late to get your holiday
mailing and shipping under control with
stamps.com sign up you'll be printing
your own postage in minutes the best
part
is basically they give you this digital
scale
all you got to do is print the postage
you weigh it on the scale it gives you
the exact postage
you put it on the package and here's the
best part they come and get it
you don't even have to do anything you
could put it in your mailbox or on your
porch and you they're gonna come and
pick it up I mean hello
what was that oh
oh yeah I just heard oh my bad that was
fine I liked it I thought it was Avant
card
uh this holiday season trade late nights
for silent nights oh so true ooh I guess
started with stamps.com today sign up
with the promo code H3 for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contrast contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code H3 I love
stamps.com there's such a uh stalwart
supporter we love stamps and appreciate
if y'all support them and thank you to
stamps so love that all right
let's do this Silent Library time okay
everybody here we are at Silent Library
[Music]
um
number two History podcast
yeah so here's the decibel counter oh my
God
what are you doing
this goes over 70 decibels it's going to
make a sound
which means we failed the round
we have 14 rounds
each person will pick a card
the person who gets the skull
has to do the round
and everybody has to be quiet
if every yes you're a lot you drink that
[ __ ] loud bro I'm trying
to drop baby I'm trying if you go
I wasn't even trying
yeah that was 64 so we're pushing it
every round
that is successfully cleared
will be two hundred dollars to the prize
pool
and money I will not sabotage I promise
[Music]
but I will be praying for your that's
his downfall
so um so those are the rules let's just
get right into it
reach out for the deck
s
so under one of these cards is a skull
all right three two one
[Music]
that's it yo we can't play we can't play
these games here are you guys setting it
off in between that's a l
um
it's a freebie you gotta chill
oh yeah
pretty good
sometimes you as you guys can see okay
so
let's do it
let's see what Dan has to do
okay
and is reaching into the giant Maga
lady in the [ __ ] that's his Lady and
the [ __ ] Sam
I think Steve will do it is going to be
here and you're gonna jerk
s
[Music]
that was true
so this
partner
it's a lady in the tree of some
spaghetti with
that you can't use your hands
he played at this
video
[Music]
that wasn't me that was dead
I don't believe
except I have not I have not said that
thing off once but the dark years
I would like to say
exactly by the way this is gonna be the
third time a kiss to do it this year all
right
well if we do it well
this is so cute
actually looks fine
I mean how much we have the
Anthony
oh so we eat from the bowl no hands
that's fine
yeah I've got a smart bit too okay do
they get one noodle
either
[Music]
either
one two one go
closer
like that
it's okay
wow
[Music]
you're good for my diet
yeah boy I can't eat carbs this is a
good game
I ate a whole pizza over the week
oh no more freebies let it the record
hold I have not set that [ __ ] off I'm a
team player oh I'm sorry everyone I'll
let you all down but you did good
that was fun do I have to take that's
enough the dog ears off yes
I'll leave mine
sorry round two it's okay
Dan doesn't have to take
you're out
what about me too still here
[Music]
all right thank you so Amy's gold now
you've got to dip your hand into the
great maggots
and hope it's not January 6th
Zach Lewis live at the instructions
[Music]
Okay so
you got the naughty maid
so maybe has to take his check
you gotta take your jacket
finally quietly
they are really easy
nice extraction
so it's my understanding
a little bit of a of a dirty lad so he
has to come get cleaned okay if I
arrested him made okay so if we could
send the maid
en I sent in the mail send in the mate
please
[Music]
look good man what's happening
okay stand at the
hey
what's this
what's this guy behind
start now
are you tickling me does it tickle no
that hurts
baby open your mouth
and I'm very sure yeah
yeah get in his pants
[Music]
you're looking real clean
a few more seconds all right
all right
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you thank you yeah you look great
beautiful I should go on the dating show
like that what are you doing later
okay congratulations
[Music]
all right
no loud spiders
yourself
I'm not turning it over
you can't prove it
damn damn that's yours
[Applause]
make up tutorial
so for this challenge we're gonna do a
makeup tutorial
Olivia's gonna go first okay with the
foundation right you want to start the
foundation come stand over here so there
you go so whenever you're ready
I I can't hear what's happening
that was foundations
oh
my gosh
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
mascara
okay just
oh mystery [ __ ]
I can't see anything
that's great
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Molly
[Applause]
[Music]
one one round yeah
that was so hard to clean off
dude I was afraid I got to come back
here and blackface she's hot bro it was
pretty bad it was pretty bad the the
mascara was
[ __ ]
all right that was racist
Shameless literally sorry all right
sorry
[Music]
tender [ __ ] all right
perfect
[Music]
okay show it to the camera now the House
of Mouse
that's interesting oh I have to ask
because Zach knows what this one is
argue down to do it
why does it get a choice
Ian's volunteering to put his body on
the line
[Music]
oh stop
it
now yeah thank you
Zach is gonna have to do
I'm going to have to try and grab a
piece
of this mouse trip
seems easy enough
you're smarter than a mouse right so
how did you wake my
[Music]
weight loss Patron
this is really interesting
I'm just worried because
his fingers are very important
[Music]
careful
I think it isn't that sensitive
thank you for Ninja
quick
you're [ __ ] red you have to do it
dude mouses give their life every day
for the [ __ ]
oh you got it off whoa
Tim you know you have to eat it eat that
[ __ ]
okay
what a boss I mean that's [ __ ]
awesome that's a dub
it's a little anticlocker
I guess someone want to put their finger
in there for 10 bucks
10 bucks
[Music]
you can slide it over there
oh my God such a baby
this is for 10 bucks
that's what I said you've acted on it
you're out
was that an accident
did it hurt did it hurt yes
oh did you break the skin a little bit
okay
I mean listen nothing snaps next
um all right this car is 2-2 that was a
beautiful job uh collaboration between
Navy and Zach but that's a dub for sure
all right what's up next
[Music]
all right three two one
[Music]
good if that's not the school you're
cheating bro all right
all right
I'll have to do it again
unrelated you look super skinny I'm not
interested
I want my skinniest ice bath oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I found that
I can do it okay right as long as I'm
I'm
just gonna dumped your head in there by
force did you watch iCarly
that episode
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here
why Olivia's gonna have to do
she slammed this half of it really
quickly get a brain freeze and then put
her face in the water oh that sounds
like five seconds
five seconds
questions
[Music]
yeah
oh my God
[Music]
yes
okay so even faster
she's not drowning right thank you
what the hell was that did you get the
brain freeze
yes okay so she got the brain
that was
something
yeah
you cut the muscles
oh that was funny oh I think it shocked
her and she laughed I think that's what
happened by the way your makeup looks
bad really yeah yeah it doesn't look
like it's really running I think maybe
it's just a tiny bit well done I'm glad
you slept up thank you thank you all
right Olivia oh my God it's totally fine
I had already done this she's like she's
like I don't want to do this too
[Music]
I mean the alarm went off
the goal post it's okay
[Music]
all right so there's Jessica left
obviously so
I know what this one okay
are you
is
[Music]
changed my shirt because I don't
know
clear on the work with me swag
did we buy them I think it was like one
of the two that he sent us did you give
that to us or did we buy it
okay okay it was a big deal
big deal okay good good it doesn't look
like
very helpful
working with me okay come on one more
time
all right here comes the skunk
oh here she comes
[Music]
is that fart spray
give me the eye and his mouth open your
mouth oh
wire champ
ions
oh it's starting to hit me
that's like what kind of challenging
and perfume
well you made the challenge
put it in his hat and his socks a new
shirt
s
I didn't smell it at all okay
look at my ears
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and it smells like burnt oven too
that's definitely a dog yeah like eating
cake as a dog some of you design harder
challenge it wasn't that bad
I don't like it right here
dancing on my wallet acting like a fat
dog
a little bit
don't do that
we're trying to we're trying to
entertain the masses
there she comes
somehow Amy always ends up
the one being punished okay
alien's punishment this is [ __ ] it's
his punishment
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
that's good that's what I'm talking
about now that's a challenge
that's good thank you Sam
and that's how we play Silent libraries
I got sprayed in the [ __ ] face bro
like your challenge is sniff a little
bit up skink spaghetti you wake the
spaghetti that's a challenge that was
dance yeah hey you remember I was the
guy getting sprayed in the [ __ ] face
Ian
oh wow that's hard
everyone went
we have a group challenge okay this is
round one of the verb stage so even
if it'll honors you pick one up
as well
shark attack
everyone's gonna participate including
the Librarians Okay so
let's let's set up for that
okay here's our first group project
shark attack
Ian has sourced some ungodly
this is Icelandic
fermented shark meat is that right
yeah this is called Hikaru can I see it
it's from Iceland hey Carl I've heard
this [ __ ] it looks like tote Brussels
looks like tofu apparently it's
fermented in their own piss or something
oh I'm not [ __ ] serious I don't know
if that's accurate
life just hurts I can already smell it
and it's not even open yet okay this
thing doesn't need to be refrigerated
like how can you have organic
like peace
[Music]
but it's juicy inside it's not even dry
like beef jerky is dry the small bucket
Juiced I don't know I don't know does
anyone speak icelandish
oh my God
does not say cupid temperature zero to
four like like what does that mean yeah
that that makes sense to me
and this [ __ ] needs to be your face
[Music]
what is
um
bring it on [ __ ]
because it says something zero to four
degrees Celsius
well 30 degrees Celsius
0 to 4.
zero up to four that's like a freezing
that's very cool yeah that's
refrigerated yes
yes temperature of a refrigerator
actually right that would be a perfect
place
[Music]
no no no no no it's k-a-e it's that a
E's yeah
at the e
okay
yeah like that k e k
K
Caleb
I don't know what the [ __ ] this website
is
[Music]
just Google translate yeah but I don't
have the right
type thing they just look up a my
Icelandic and then copy paste it
okay
Sammy's trying to kill us bro you take
this game too far Sam
foreign
Celsius
Refrigeration product bro you've got
that means refrigerated product perfect
zero to four degrees this [ __ ] was
shipped to us from Iceland room
temperature
hell no probably you eat that hand he'll
eat that
the fridge is in it like but the salmon
like you know
this is letting me know it's an animal
Sam's eating this
let's see let's smell it now let's just
nobody needs to please
I'm wondering because I have a phobia
mom should I smell first then
for you guys
[Music]
but if you get up and run and make noise
I'm telling you from here on out just
remember your team no no no I said I
think I saved y'all's life some of you
all were gonna try this year
zero to four maybe they're just legally
obligated to say it let's get to my
refrigerator
it says
it's it's
there it is okay now as you can see
clearly states
get a load of this [ __ ] bro that is not
right yeah that ain't right it even has
an expiration date so how's that
possible
[Music]
it has an expiration date
yeah that's what it is let's [ __ ] go
let's grab that channel
oh
[ __ ] oh shoot
whoa
oh
[Music]
walk out the way
it's happening it's happening
[Music]
see that's good it's sealed time
here's the one I read online maybe it's
like refrigerator
okay from now on no sound
right his own oh my God
oh my God
yo
yo
that is
that like Burns and it burns okay I'm
gonna do it hey can you get sick from
smelling something
it's like industrial chemical
that's [ __ ] insane
just process it doesn't it doesn't it
does travel as much
in there
he's got some glue on my thumb
let's dig finger finger on top
bro
my best
[Music]
[Music]
okay seriously
next
time
okay let's want you to eat that [ __ ] oh
no no
[Music]
she's Unstoppable
holy [ __ ] I just want that
yes
[Music]
there we go
foreign
oh
she got the new jacket Amy go to the
bathroom did you Yak in it I think he
survived I think he survived dude just
pretend it's a chunk of mango bro
no way oh my God
that is unlike anything
you're right
we're entering round two
at least
so what's the score right now right now
did we win that last one
[Music]
actually somehow
I don't know how we cleared that round
all right ready three two
one
all right Zach we have a meat grinder we
need to put your fingers slowly through
it
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we have here Zach's
challenge which is quite quite elaborate
this is the Clockwork Rosebud yes
which is a compilation of two great
films is that right Citizen Kane and yes
[Music]
wrapped up in the inversion table our
Librarians are going to hold it hold his
eyes open he has to watch this video
through its entirety okay and we have to
oh God okay so Zach do you
you can say it do you consider having a
bit of a Howie moment
yeah what does that mean like am I gonna
here he's gonna see you graphic
pornography
Zach said that's my world okay
I was born in it all right here we go
proud
oh no
so you guys can't see what it is
[Music]
what I'm sorry I can't pretend that I
didn't just see that
point you're going to see a lot more of
it
[Music]
do you want me to pretend I didn't just
relaxing on each other
that was the gnarliest thing I've ever
seen you didn't just like look you can't
just ask me to pretend reset
oh is that is that hunger
I think so
just go ahead
[Music]
oh
his eyes open tomorrow
we're not passing it just play it just
play it I don't want to look at this
much
I want to see your reactions
refresh the page
yes so if you guys want to know there's
two dudes like holy prologue super like
juicy and juice to help prolapse and
then someone starts putting their finger
and like poking it out yeah and like and
like pressure there you go perfect if I
had to describe the size of that thing
it was like a big rusted potato it looks
good was Lena going too hard
you know why because she was freaking
out too I I I knew that
yeah you use the audio because we
already failed it
holy [ __ ]
dude that's bigger than a russet oh my
God
dude what the [ __ ] the bubbles oh my god
dude you better look at that look at the
guys yeah I've seen a good amount oh my
God there's like a slug coming out of
his body
dude I can't believe what I'm saying I
actually can't look in here
oh my God
[Applause]
it's
the cranberry sauce they're Thanksgiving
they're stuffing their prolap their ass
to ass and they're stuffing the prolapse
yeah it's canned uh cranberries
oh my God
whoa
that was insane bro how you gonna go
from smelling
microwave that hard drive please okay
that was great
hold on we can't all just forget
something
because that was transformative we gotta
post that on Twitter
I think it's doing
on Twitter yeah I've never seen it
anymore
it's not safe for work
that's how I say for Humanity
[Music]
three two one
I'm not turning it over
there
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Okay so
the Queen of England has come back she's
left her box and she has some Revenge to
enact on me so here comes the queen
she's got a big old ball of beans
is that the real [ __ ] she looks just
like the queen is that the realize
that's absolutely
can we see me thank you Elizabeth
well I can't believe that
I'm Shuffling dude wait
ERS
[Music]
it's all right this way
I think I beat boarded him
are you done
don't stress me I'm [ __ ] dude
stop it I'm here with me it's okay I
don't know my notes all right all right
all right nice work
can I take this off this one's for the
queen bro I said that was [ __ ] off
you literally just water aboarded me
with pink
I literally couldn't breathe that was
[ __ ] if is there any more challenges
where you had to get in a suit no you
Okay so
[Music]
yeah
I'll put up in Lizzie's [ __ ] box of
big feet
by the way I literally got waterboarded
by [ __ ] big things it was about my
nose I couldn't agree a crazy
dare you guys shush me baby
I'm saying we're gonna go out like like
this I said we all know it anyway s
that was horrible that was absolutely
awesome
fire ready three three two one yes
I love that I don't know
okay so for this challenge
Dan is going to have to melt
you got a milk
it comes oh this is nice so this is how
the hurricane was looking for
okay
[Music]
put your hands down put your hands down
yes
like a mother tutor cap
a baby
yes yes yes
drink more child
grow up nice and strong child
milk them harder hard work that nipple
camera
work that nipple boy baby needs more
milk
[Music]
all right now y'all are just getting
into it
Jesus oh that was good that was funny
[ __ ] I did not expect that well I guess
that was a fail also at one point it was
way farther in your mouth than I thought
it was yeah
and then it started dripping out and I'm
like you do a great camera
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
that one actually I think it was my
fault for the first time it was 70.1
thanks bro
all right okay
oh
this is going to be an eating challenge
I'm sure of now okay who else
[Music]
wow
that don't sound right
all right so maybe you're strapped up to
the period simulator
got the control
so he's going to have to paint something
uh I think you should decide when he has
something
for prolapse prolapse
I always
I don't think you're gonna be accurate
enough to set off any sense here's my
bro not that I don't have faith in your
ability okay so what are we going back
in 60 Seconds
yeah
okay sweetheart
I don't know how we're ready all right
all right three two one go
okay
is it going yeah
that's a red circle it's beautiful
oh [ __ ] I didn't do anything
you got this yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's good
yes
[Music]
five
thank you one zero
I'm putting it down are you okay holy
[ __ ] bro that's [ __ ]
that'd look kind of good though I think
he's technically survived no yeah I'll
give it to you all right
[Applause]
well done that prolapse looks right I
know I nailed it I actually like that
yeah definitely actually more of the
video from today yeah good job baby
class here we go
[Music]
he's very nervous about one in
particular and it's
eating and Ian is like the metal trap of
the show
he knows what it is and he's scared and
[ __ ] would you rather do baked beans or
this
ah
every day really whoa
all right yes
[Music]
you got it yes you got it yeah
you got it
a chance
Jeff wedding eyeballs are they blue or
green or more Brown
damn all right
what do you know yeah what is this
you got to explain what that is you're
the host sorry there's always a chance
Revenge because I'm trying to keep
David's eyes there's a bunch of things
that Sam gone and don't breaks pizza so
it's it's liquefied pizza ice cream
it matters is my chocolate
added
understanding how can you be so dramatic
it sounds great these are extra
chili powder
Malibu yes
the mouth was a nice touch
that sounds like a nice dessert yes yeah
what's the white
it's chocolate cake
that's good
chocolate made that sound worse
all right take this David you [ __ ]
this one's for you
Jesse
it just looks juicy
[Music]
three you're telling me three slices of
Delbert went into that where's the other
slices
you got this
come on do it do it
let's go for Chef Crunchy just get a
look at that under the
end of the Hedgehog clip so let's see
what the Flesh of it actually looks like
it's green I've never seen a gag
that looks pretty gnarly turn it so you
can take it yeah that's that's pretty
wild bro
[Music]
you'll eat a whole one that's pretty
gangster
[Music]
yeah yeah definitely
broke to your [ __ ] God
why does that look s wow
[Music]
look like
oh
it doesn't look like that
it's like speaking at the time
[Music]
that looks like
a
yeah
[Music]
it's dying
[Music]
son is off screen like
how are you doing this
he's flipping off his girlfriend
just eat the goo bruh
Twilight cover
[Music]
that looks like a muffin with green food
coloring let's try
some Summer Challenge you want some
beans in here
there's so long to eat it
[Music]
all right here
he's coming home Mom it's coming up it's
coming up it's coming up
[Music]
for England it tastes like a birthday
finishes
[Music]
oh yeah
it's coming home Mom oh my God
[Music]
you gotta get the chocolate I changed my
mind what the [ __ ] because it's true it
goes down too easy bro
welcome well it is the daily challenge
it goes down too easy
is the chocolates the hard part
it's not my challenge listen you created
this you created this challenge there's
literally mucus
yeah
congratulations
[Music]
oh my God the chocolate's probably good
right
is probably good
let's draw is quivering
places
[Music]
it can't be that bad right
that looks so [ __ ] up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no it's just pizza
let's take a bite
take a bite is it Frozen
it's how do you consume wait you put
gelatin
oh
hell no
all right that's why Tom yeah
by the way you guys can watch the
creation of all of these challenges in
the BTS we're posting this week
Sam recorded it all so that's going to
be out now and well done
there's only one challenge left Olivia
so let's not play games
[Music]
okay we got weights and fish
oh hell yeah
hell yeah
oh that was so close 69 okay okay
[Music]
you got a big one
we're handling girl
[Music]
um
finisher
keep going no mercy you gotta pull it
off
no no no you stay seated
you gotta pull it off find it it's the
catch of your life
it's a big one
hey can you get a close-up
wait hold on hold on
what the [ __ ] was that
okay
Elena realer and close the deal oh Jesus
don't touch it
pull it you gotta take it off
[Music]
all right all right we did it wow
man that should stretched
all right so we are on to the final
challenge
job everybody I thought we you know good
effort by everybody obviously I had it
the worst by far
um Tomatoes you know
not available
[Music]
[Music]
that for us so we all watch it
we'll bring out his final errors we're
like die in seven days it's like the
right tags
hey [ __ ] you for not coming to my
birthday party [ __ ] you I'll see you
after last laugh at your [ __ ]
he said he said you're too good for my
party I bet your Carter could go to suck
stick
hey Ethan I thought we were friends
[ __ ] I can't believe you [ __ ]
me like that Hallelujah I thought we did
a dad for the strippers party you bailed
on me [ __ ] hey Apex I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up
you [ __ ] the only person excuse
me the rest of you [ __ ] you
Merry Christmas you filthy [ __ ]
wow
we we deserve that yeah
all right we deserve that either but so
what's this under this right it's a
special
cupcake birthday
myself I'm done
hell no
this is the EDP cupcake
[ __ ] bro
I don't know dude down to the prolapse
[Music]
why does it look so look so [ __ ]
juicy dude Jacob's very responsible
[Music]
why does it have
a cap on it
must be
just me boy baby I had your last one
last night
just for the record
I guess you do all them for the last one
you know what this smells like I was
gonna throw you under the bus
[Music]
am I doing
it was a prologue
tell me what's in it
it's the cake normal like
yeah
no the cake is normal
pictures
like yeah
so
much
jelly
doesn't have like foreskin in it does it
[Music]
all right
just jelly I don't know what I'm doing
and it scares me
[Music]
you gotta take a bite over here
it doesn't seem like it's that like
[Music]
after
she got toothpaste I want a chair no
that's toothpaste
it's not too big bro you might be
realign that they don't care about
trying to kill us
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you're best
oh
right here buddy
we're in this together you [ __ ] came
harder than anyone's but it's true it's
true
working like me the cars
oh my God he's about to kill the curse
okay it is
Greek yogurt
it was delicious uh blue cheese okay
there we go yeah horseradish
Jesus no it's the Greek yogurt you know
how much I hate that [ __ ] oh my gosh and
what Ranch oh what is wrong with you
yeah
[Applause]
Amy is this toothpaste you know what no
oh but it's not too fast maybe put the
whole thing in his mouth and then he
goes and spits it all out he didn't even
really chew it well Ethan would you put
it all in your mouth and then spit it
out then yeah it's easy but why would I
do that because you're saying you're
defending your man so what so okay
it's very jelly it's annoying to have in
your mouth why am I doing this
because he said it's not a big deal I
didn't say it's not a big deal do it
[ __ ] it's still [ __ ] coating my
throat man oh
he put it all together
oh my God wait let the rose yeah
you know what I think I've seen that
movie before yeah it's earlier tonight
yeah oh
my god well I just prolapsed from my
mouth yeah
so we go
we survived we gotta get it out I'm
sorry Gabe
did we pass that one no that was a no
that was another video
so seven it was all the same stuff just
without gelatin that's why it isn't like
a puck like everybody else so that was
seven wins seven losses it's a nice 50
win ratio and pull that up
so at the end of the day that's what
1400 bucks uh right yeah split between
uh the crew so thank you very much thank
you Ethan all right well there it is
this year's Silent Library thanks for
your viewing pleasure why did we do this
again
[Music]